foreign
[Music]
as you can see Israel has built a
separation wall
[Music]
we're starting outside a settlement
called itamar heading to another one
called Ariel both them illegal under
international law these roads are smooth
and new their primary design for
settlers in the occupied West Bank the
Israeli government spending around a
quarter of its entire Transportation
Budget on roads here
[Music]
going on Palestinian roads you can feel
shaking
here there's an Israeli road that can
only be used by Israelis
along so many of these roads that have
been primarily built for settlers there
are sometimes dozens of military
checkpoints put in place to protect
those settlers traveling from A to B we
have a Palestinian dedicated app that
shows the route that Palestinians can
take when they want to go from one place
to another everything is unpredictable
you might have roadblocks checkpoints
settler attacks
here we are arriving at the second one
hey how are you
uh
I'm a journalist journalist
London London yeah
GPO card so that's the first time we've
been checked on this entire Journey just
as we get to our destination this is one
of the notorious roads for Palestinians
the huge really get stuck here for hours
and hours because at the end of this
road there is the kalandia checkpoint
that is the main link between
brahmallah and Jerusalem and for us we
cannot go there only yellow plated cars
can go inside only Palestinians who have
permits and even if they have permits
they cannot drive their cars inside they
have to go in walking and there's a
bottleneck that makes this traffic and
it shows really here how politics
control the smallest details of
Palestinians lives
foreign